elle s'appelle marie lee crépeau elle a
27 ans et elle a donné naissance à laura
lee il ya sept mois
voici jessica benedicto 37,1 firmament
de lorenzo quatre mois de nouvelles
mères deux expériences fort différentes
la première à bétou nord de montréal
l'autre à toronto
nous sommes au centre médical willis et
l'infirmière enregistre le poids et la
taille du petit lorenzo
ils doivent recevoir aujourd'hui un
rappel de vaccin comme tous les poupons
de son âge
des doses sont disponibles sur place et
en moins de cinq minutes le tour est
joué petit son collègue rendez-vous de
routine qui illustre bien la qualité des
soins que reçoivent jessica
pourtant sa grossesse n'a pas été facile
son bébé se développe être au lendemain
et elle a dû recevoir un suivi
particulier
mais jamais elle ne s'est sentis
négligés
en clinique à terrebonne marily doit
noter elle même le poids de son enfant
québec il faut être débrouillard dès le
premier suivi de grossesse ou m'ont
donné panoplie de l'état
[Musique]
en ontario c'est la clinique qui fait
ses démarches auprès d'un gynécologue
les rappels de vaccins ou s'ils sont
plus compliqués au québec ça aussi ça a
été tu exposes assez compliqué darcos
est laissée avant des rendez vous
j'étais en les heurtant la place mon
prix
je pense pas c'est anecdotique teum teum
ont été confrontés à saint denis
chênevert de l'université de montréal
n'est pas étonné depuis des années
l'accès aux soins de première ligne au
québec et pénible on n'a pas réussi à
bien cadrer les accès de première ligne
et donc les gens se retrouvent dans
l'hôpital l'homme aux urgences et alors
qu'ils devraient pas se retrouver dans
ces endroits là j'ai appelé mon médecin
fallait y avait pas faire pendant deux
ou trois mois mais l'oeil se
nourrissaient juste plus était capable
de rire
en ontario jessica peut s'attendre à
voir son médecin un médecin de garde ou
une infirmière praticienne dans les 24
heures
au québec marie lee doit prendre un
rendez vous pour une plage s'en rendit
2g
et pourtant selon les dernières données
on trouve plus d'omnipraticiens par cent
mille habitants au québec qu'en ontario
soit 129 contre 115 même chose pour les
médecins spécialistes
128 contre 114 le québec dépensent aussi
plus d'argent par habitant en santé l'an
dernier c'était 7 1913 dollars contre 7
1773 ce n'est donc pas un problème de
ressources mais d'organisation selon ce
spécialiste des politiques publiques on
lance des réformes pendant des périodes
d'expansion tu viennes des périodes de
contraction des finances publiques on a
laissé beaucoup de nous réformer en
plein on n'obtient que le pire se dire
les changements les transformations le
malaise mais on n'obtient pas la fin les
fruits qui était attendu
les ciels s'ils sont un bon exemple
très souvent les étrangers nous parle
encore des services et en disant je
descends au québec c'est fantastique le
modèle du clsc québécois on en part
toujours le modèle a même inspiré
l'ontario dans sa propre réforme
rappelle la docteure danielle martin de
l'université de toronto mais le succès
ontarien comporte aussi un autre
ingrédient indien au médecin ou êtes
sans charge de cette population de 1000
personnes on vous paie par personne par
mois un changement du mode de
rémunération
cette approche là qui est vraiment
centré sur le patient ce qui a sans
doute encouragé des omnipraticiens comme
catherine rouleau à se consacrer presque
exclusivement au travail en clinique
c'est devenu très clair un certain
moment donné que je ne pouvais pas bien
prendre soin des patients être présente
et faire de l'urgence à manta les
médecins québécois sont ceux qui passent
le moins de temps cabinet au canada
résultat ils voient aussi moins de
patients c'est sûr que j'aurais plus de
place au bureau si je faisais pas de
salle accouchement est ce que c'est
vraiment ce qui permettrait à mes
patients d'avoir des meilleurs soins
gabriel côté vachon se spécialise dans
les suivis obstétrique à son avis forcer
les médecins à rester en clinique serait
contreproductif pour moi la médecine
familiale ç'a toujours été des suivent
une patiente enseignes de la couche et
de suivre son bébé elle croit que la
solution passe plutôt par un meilleur
partage des responsabilités en
particulier avec les infirmières mais
privé de l'activité médicale qui
valorise le plus je pense pas que ce
serait dans ses rues et sa personne
[Musique]
comme jessica marie lee apprécie
beaucoup son médecin de famille le
problème n'est jamais dans le service
mais dans l'effort pour l'obtenir parce
que de lorenzo alors ali de l'ontario au
québec les besoins eux sont toujours les
mêmes
[Musique]